-We don't always
have time enough
to cover all of the recent news,
so here with a recap is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What."
♪♪♪♪
-Whoo! You guys,
things have been crazy!
First of all, no one works
in the White House anymore.
Sean Spicer was out,
and I was like, "What?!"
Then Reince Priebus was out,
Then to top it all off,
Scaramucci was out
after just ten days,
and I was like, "What?!"
But then I found out
Steve Bannon
was still working there,
and I was like, "What...?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then I found out
the Boy Scouts invited Trump
to give a speech,
and I was like,
"Ha-ha-ha! Why?!"
Then he started talking
to these children
about a guy getting laid
on a yacht,
and I was like,
"Ha-ha-ha! What?!"
Then he had those kids
booing Obama,
and I was like, "Ha-ha. What?"
[ Laughter ]
Then the people who made
"Game of Thrones" announced
they're working on another show
called "Confederate"
that imagines if the South
had successfully seceded
from the union
and slavery
had never been abolished.
I heard that and was like,
"What the [bleep]?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
But then Amazon announced
that they were also working on
a show called "Black America"
that imagines
if newly freed slaves
had formed their own nation,
and I was like, "What...
a new and interesting idea."
Then the best thing
in the world happened.
During a hearing of the House
Financial Services Committee,
Representative Maxine Waters
asked Treasury Secretary
Steve Mnuchin
why he hadn't responded to a
letter she had sent him. Watch.
-Everything that you've done
for the community there.
-Thank you very much for that.
I don't want to take my time --
-I also have appreciated
the opportunity...
-Reclaiming my time.
...to meet with you
several times.
-Reclaiming my time.
Reclaiming my time.
-The time belongs to the
gentlelady from California.
-With the House...
-Reclaiming my time.
Reclaiming my time.
-With the Senate...
-Reclaiming my time.
-Okay.
-Mr. Chairman, I thought
when you read the rules,
you acknowledged that
I shouldn't be interrupted
and that I would have --
-Reclaiming my time.
What he failed to tell you
was when you're on my time,
I can reclaim it.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo! Whoo!
I saw that and was like,
"What...better way
to shut a fool up."
Then they voted against
the repeal of Obamacare,
and I was like, "What-what!"
Then everyone was like,
"John McCain voted no!
He saved us!"
And I was like,
"What...about Susan Collins
and Lisa Murkowski?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
And yesterday, I read
that the Justice Department
is investigating affirmative
action in college admissions,
and I was like, "Good! We need
more affirmative action."
But then I found out
that the Trump administration
is going to use resources
allocated for civil rights
to investigate colleges
for discriminating
against white people.
Then I said, "What?" so fast,
it broke the sound barrier.
It was like this.
What?!
[ Laughter ]
That worked well.
But, hey, I'm all for white
people getting an education.
Then there won't be so many
people voting for Trump.
This has been "Amber Says What."
♪♪♪♪
-Ladies and gentlemen,
give it up for Amber Ruffin.
-Reclaiming my time!
Reclaiming my time.
Amber Ruffin, everybody.
-Okay.